gary sanbrook thank you very much mr
speaker um yesterday in an attempt to
boost morale in the tea room the prime
minister said uh a table but there were
seven people mps in the carlton club
last week and one of them should have
tried to intervene to stop chris from
drinking so much as if that wasn't
insulting enough to the people who did
try and intervene that night and then
also to the victims that drink was the
problem isn't it the example mr speaker
but it's the prime minister constantly
tries to deflect from the issue always
tries to blame other people for mistakes
and that at least nothing um left for
him to do other than to take
responsibility and resign
order
can i just say you want to be
embarrassed by clapping this is not a
debate
mr esterson it's not debating society
this is
this is prime minister's questions i
want to get through the questions as
other people want to catch my eye and
the way to do it is not by clapping
prime minister mr speaker there's a very
simple reason why they want me out and
that is and that is and that is because
and that is because they know mr speaker
that you think that otherwise we are
going to get on and deliver our mandate
and win another general election and
that is the reality mr speaker